yeah part of what's been driving the
results at the moment are new cancer
drug launches that's been the story with
Pfizer Merck and bristol-myers there
have been new cancer immunotherapies
that have come to the market in the last
few months and another breast cancer
drug and these drugs are getting pretty
strong uptake in the initial and their
initial launches in the market so that's
why are the therapies doing so well
given that they are just so expensive
yeah that's part of the story here these
drugs can be anywhere from a hundred to
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year for patients but at the moment the
insurers and the payers are actually
paying for the drugs so so some of the
big cancer centers are able to use them
for as some of the first new lines of
therapy in Cynthia we're looking at that
graph on the screen tell us what we're
looking at so these are the three
different drugs
Keit ruta and opdivo are immunotherapies
and these are drugs that harness the
immune system to help launch the attack
on on the tumor and it branches is
Pfizer's breast cancer drug and that
drug has been launched in one type of
breast cancer and it'll likely get
broader approvals as the year goes on
and as we said look at them all three of
them over six figures that is expensive
what's the outlook for these new drugs
coming to the market well what's
happening now is they're studying these
drugs and lots of different types of
tumors so presumably what's happening
now is just the very beginning and
there'll be a number of different
cancers that these will be used in and
cancers where there are much bigger
patient populations so that's that sort
of the end goal here is being able to
take these therapies and apply them to
many different patient populations in
combination as well as on their own what
about the major risks of these outlooks
what are they the risk is that basically
these drugs compete against one another
and that the insurers get tough on
pricing and that the drug makers aren't
able to charge 100 to 150,000 per course
but that hasn't happened yet so we have
to wait and see and again for the
pharmaceutical companies the therapies
keep coming out and the profits keep
going yet they've been able to deliver
so far so the question is how applicable
is this how many different types of
patient populations can they reach into
and how long will they be able to
sustain this momentum Cynthia when we
talk about these therapies is there any
one that some of the pharmaceutical
companies are saying you know what this
looks so promise
we might be getting close to announcing
not a cure but to give people some hope
really now they're looking at
combination therapies because while
these all these drugs look really good
on their own I think what what the
community sees really is that once
they're put together they're gonna have
even better results and so I don't think
any one therapy stands out as this is
the real hope for the future I think
what what their investigators are
looking at now is how can we team some
of these drugs up to see far better
results in cancers than we've ever seen
before